Đây là giọng đủ tỉn xào đồng không bởi giữ viet trụi
Công thây thành năng chính đư dài câu đủ tỉn khó nha này
Công thương, nó cho mắt đủ khó lời
Nào, đây là mấy là người ta cho mốt thế nữa là bạn, các bạn nào nào
Mình nghĩa người phê sẽ còn số trác chứ
Nó sẽ hiểm dùng
Bây giờ, lúc cái mình thấy rằng cái gì mình cận cái gì mình thiết
Bởi vì tỉn mỏ
Bây giờ, cái năng gọi số trởi nó là một cái năng cơ của quan trọng
Nhà, trong nếu tỉn khá luôn
Trong nhiệp tình rất hiểu của tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn
Cái hà như quả nhé
Nào, em nghĩ tuổi đấy, thời điểm, đây là bạn không
Nó năng bởi vì chỉ có nó, mấy cái gì này, hoa nhiều
Bây giờ, anh đang có suy nghĩa bạn, đang có suy tăng
Bây giờ không biết thì không nó có suy tăng ở đâu thì có thể biểu gì mà có thể đưa nào đó
Túng không?
Mình không biết thì biểu gì nữa mình ra, suy tích nó mấy đi
Là, suy tích nó, ngon, ngon, ngon, ngon này không có suy tích nó mấy bạn
Đúng không?
Bây giờ, cái đây chỉ là thời điểm tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn quý tỉn
Cái này có suy tích nó, không có suy tích nó
Bây giờ, thế bây giờ, mình mạnh tính quá nửa
Tính là ra cho thế bù khoảng nhan nữa
Tính khoảng hút thấy gì là hòa ra này
Đó là khoảng nửa ra thì tìm, tìa hay thì tìa bà, tòng một xe khóc lực
Cụ đúng không, xe khoảng nhan lời, em sao?
Thằng ngày đó sẽ tạc nó có quay bò nhiều, thì mình tính quý tỉn quý này
Cụ không, mình tính quý này nhé
Có quay này trên đi, mấy nó có ngả quá, nó chỉ có ngả
Đúng rồi, có quay này trên đi, mấy nó chỉ có ngả
Tìa có lấy thế nào, đi ăn tập phi thì nó xong có mấy ngả, cái nha thế
Búng không, lấy mình không phải ngả phi, nhìn người là một phải ngang dây
Bởi vì nha, xơi đi, bà bi trên bù, nè mà
Bà bi trên bù nó nó sẽ góc bão nhiều nhỉ
Bù bi là một trong tả mới đồ, bà bi trên bù nó sẽ tình đường nha có một trong má mẹn đồ
Tức là có ngày mà một trong má là nụ
Bà dấu nhé, bà dấu nhé
Thái đồ, nó sẽ xonga này, đây là bóng được gì chuyển từ từ điểm măn lâu
Bình tật điểm tây hai, quá, quá được gì chuyển từ tây bằng không
Bình tây hai, nó sẽ hằng bà mời, chủ năng cạnh hà
Tìa có 1 xam rất thay xam từ tây bằng không, mình tây hai nó sẽ đi qua những quan đường nha